c'est la rentrée littéraire des premiers
romans il n'y en a jamais eu autant
cette année un livre sur quatre est
publié par un débutant
la benjamine d'entre eux n'a que 19 ans
faïza guène signe kifkif demain un livre
drôle et plein d'espoir qui raconte la
banlieue autrement alexandra garde jean
pierre ryckmans il s'est pas positionné
s'aggrave la sebli que je vais vous dire
mais si ça passait devant la grosse
photo elle est d'un naturel déconcertant
d'une franchise ébouriffante spontanée
pas blasé juste ravie elle est comme ça
faiza pas du style à garder sa langue
dans sa poche et encore moins sa plume
à 19 ans elle l'a 30 pour la première
fois dans le vitriol et raconte le
quotidien d'une jeune beurette de
banlieue qui vit seul avec sa mère femme
de ménage
vous avez la vision tu vas de l'auteur
avec là bas ça fait dix ans qu'on galère
au plus d'efforts aux moines et comptait
pas toutes les portes se fait jeter il
pleut dehors elle tombe en escrime nous
y est tout est en fait là bas ça c'est
facile mais elle écrit depuis qu'elle
est en âge de tenir un stylo faiza et
son héroïne lui ressemble étrangement
née de parents algériens la banlieue de
pantin et son quotidien
c'est là qu'elle a grandi ce mais sans
jamais manqué de rien alors pas question
pour elle est attaquée ou de faire
pleurer
c'était une vision complètement
différente de la banlieue avec une
pleine d'espoir et enfin pas négative
surtout pas négative j'essaie de faire
en sorte que son petit peu frais ce que
des trucs de les voitures qui brûlent
les mecs au chômage de tous les drogues
tout en sachant toujours décalé faiza à
la maison de quartier qu'elle fréquente
assidûment depuis l'âge de 13 ans ses
amis ne sont pas et aunis mais quelle
fierté ses parents
arriver à faire ce qu'a fait tout seul
en plus c'est pour nous tous et beaucoup
à s'en rend pas compte mais c'est
vraiment bien il m'a rappelé molière ce
qu'on l'a dans la peau
laisse tomber demos mais aussi des
images pour parler de sa cité faïza
guène a aussi réalisé un moyen métrage
actuellement à l'affiché de plusieurs
festivals avec son style son travail et
sa personnalité slavin jammine de la
rentrée à tous pour durer